Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Elle et moi,
on s’est rencontrées il y a 14 ans.
Je l’avais déjà vue avant,
mais j’ai vraiment appris à l’apprécier
ces derniers temps.
Elle me répète toujours :
« L’eau, c’est la vie.
L'eau, c'est le lien.
L’eau, c’est le partage. »
Elle, c’est Ingo,
une toute petite goutte d’eau.
Son nom signifie « eau protectrice »
en langue kanak.
Je la connais bien parce
que je bosse pour elle.
Je coordonne les actions publiques dans
le domaine de l’eau en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Un sacré challenge quand on connaît
le mille-feuille administratif local.
(Rires)
L’aventure d’Ingo débute lorsque,
sous forme de pluie,
elle quitte un nuage qui survole
la Nouvelle-Calédonie - mon pays.
Pendant sa chute, Ingo calcule que son
voyage va durer quelques heures à peine,
car la Nouvelle-Calédonie
est une toute petite île,
perdue dans l’immense océan Pacifique.
Captée par les feuilles d’un arbre,
son atterrissage sur terre
se fait en douceur.
Elle saute de branche en branche
et ruisselle le long du tronc
du magnifique banyan qui l’a accueillie.
Du haut de ce point de vue,
Ingo se rend compte que
la forêt est en mauvais état.
Il ne reste plus que
les grands et vieux arbres,
le sous-bois a disparu.
Mais Maman Arbre lui explique que c’est
à cause des cochons sauvages et des cerfs.
Oui, les « cerfes »,
c’est comme ça qu’on dit chez nous.
(Rires)
Les cerfs, donc,
qui dévorent les jeunes pousses,
les futures générations de forêts.
Les mamans Arbres lui parlent
aussi de leur peur du feu,
ce feu qui est toujours d’origine humaine,
qui détruit tout sur son passage
et qui assèche les sols.
Quarante-trois millions
d’hectares de forêts
ont disparu dans le monde
ces 20 dernières années.
Ingo est triste, car elle sait que
les forêts sont une éponge naturelle,
un abri privilégié pour les gouttes d'eau.
Si la forêt disparaît, l'eau disparaît.
Ingo s’infiltre à présent le long
des racines et rejoint la rivière.
Elle se laisse porter
et découvre les mines,
qui défrichent une énorme quantité
de terres et de sols
pour extraire un pourcentage
assez faible de minéraux précieux.
(Rires)
Oui, elle m’a tannée pour qu’on aille voir
le Seigneur des anneaux - cinq fois !
(Rires)
Elle entend les coups des pelles
mécaniques et le roulement des camions
qui emportent loin cette terre autrefois
cocon douillet pour la forêt et pour elle.
Elle découvre aussi les industries
qui utilisent une énorme quantité d’eau
pour refroidir les fours ou les machines.
L’irremplaçable électricité est fabriquée
grâce à des milliards de milliards
de mètres cubes d’eau
dans des centrales nucléaires
ou des barrages hydro-électriques.
Ces barrages retiennent l’eau,
vitale pour les arbres situés à l’aval,
et empêchent le déplacement des poissons.
Qui d’entre vous se souvient
de l’orque Willy,
celui qui réussit à sauter au-dessus
d’une digue pour retrouver sa liberté ?
Mauvaise nouvelle :
les poissons n’y arrivent pas.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ingo longe à présent des grandes
étendues utilisées pour l’agriculture.
Elle sait qu’elle est indispensable
pour alimenter les hommes,
puisque 70 % des gouttes d’eau
utilisées dans le monde
servent à faire pousser des fruits,
des légumes ou à abreuver des troupeaux.
Elle a lu qu'il fallait 13 000 litres
d'eau pour obtenir un kilo de steak.
Oui, Ingo traîne sur Facebook.
(Rires)
13 mètres cubes, 13 tonnes d’eau,
pour une côte de bœuf.
Ça vient des réseaux sociaux,
c’est forcément vrai,
mais Ingo n’en revient pas.
Elle découvre aussi le gaspillage
lorsqu’elle se retrouve dans le réseau
d’alimentation en eau potable,
ces tuyaux qui apportent l’eau
jusqu’à notre robinet.
Elle découvre les fuites,
les robinets qui restent ouverts,
la surconsommation.
En Nouvelle-Calédonie, certaines communes
enregistrent des consommations
qui vont jusqu’à 1 600 litres
par jour et par personne.
C’est 13 fois plus que la consommation
quotidienne d’un Parisien
et 66 fois plus que celle d’un Ougandais.
D’ailleurs,
sait-on d’où vient l’eau
qui coule à nos robinets
et que notre eau est de meilleure qualité
si la forêt dont elle est issue
est en bon état ?
Après avoir été utilisée
comme eau potable -
jusque dans nos toilettes -
Ingo se retrouve
dans le réseau des eaux usées.
Elle a peur :
elle n’est plus belle et bleue,
elle est devenue gris très foncé.
Elle angoisse de savoir si elle va rester
de cette couleur toute sa vie,
car ça ruine complètement
son profil Instagram.
(Rires)
S’il y a des fosses septiques
en sortie des maisons
ou des stations d’épuration
pour l’assainissement collectif,
peu d’obligations existent
dans le monde à ce jour,
C’est la porte ouverte à la pollution
des rivières et des océans
par les bactéries
issues des matières fécales.
Seuls 20 % des eaux utilisées dans
les maisons seront traitées et nettoyées
avant d’être rejetées dans la nature.
Vingt pour cent.
Ingo retrouve à présent le lagon,
ses cocotiers, ses plages de sable blanc.
Enfin, presque.
Elle repense à tous les cacas
qu’elle a croisés avant -
(Chante) A tous les cacas
qu’elle a croisés avant,
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
(Chante) à tous les pesticides
et les métaux polluants.
Bref, elle réalise
qu’elle est indispensable pour
les arbres, les poissons,
mais aussi les mines, l’industrie,
l’agriculture, l’eau potable,
l’eau de baignade,
partagée entre fierté et découragement.
À côté de ça, d’autres gouttes d’eau
qui ont visité d’autres pays
lui racontent les rivalités d’usage
qui existent autour de l’eau.
Le Nil, par exemple, qui traverse 11 pays
et abreuve 500 millions de personnes,
est au cœur de fortes tensions
politiques et militaires.
Ingo comprend que, grâce à elle,
des guerres sont déclarées.
Ouais, ok, j’avoue,
ça ne va pas fort pour Ingo.
Heureusement, elle m’en parle,
je lui remonte le moral,
ça évite qu’on retrouve des
antidépresseurs dans ses analyses qualité.
Pour vous dire quand même :
si Ingo était tombée sur la côte
ouest des États-Unis en juillet 2021,
elle aurait été témoin de la plus grave
sécheresse de ces 70 dernières années.
Elle se serait sûrement évaporée
avant même d’avoir touché le sol.
Exactement au même moment,
si Ingo était tombée en Europe,
elle aurait participé aux inondations
qui ont noyé 230 personnes
en Allemagne et en Belgique.
Toujours à la même minute,
si Ingo était tombée à Madagascar,
elle aurait pu aider ces millions
de personnes qui font face à la famine,
famine due à un manque d’eau chronique
lié aux déforestations massives
dans ce pays.
Pour Ingo, c’en est trop
et elle m’a transmis un message.
« Chers amis !
Vous êtes composés
à 70 % de gouttes d’eau.
Je suis donc inquiète et effrayée
pour votre santé, votre survie.
Mon cycle naturel, qui est lié
à celui des forêts,
se dérègle depuis de nombreuses années.
Canicules, inondations, sécheresses,
incendies incontrôlables
sont autant d’alertes
que vous n’écoutez pas.
Qu’est-ce que vous ne comprenez pas ?
Qu’est-ce qui vous empêche d’agir ?
Qu’est-ce qui vous gêne ? »
C’est la musique larmoyante, c’est ça ?
Guéno, s’il te plaît,
arrête la musique larmoyante.
Tu arrêtes la musique, s’il te plaît ?
Ouais. Tu n’as pas autre chose ?
(Musique entraînante)
Guéno, tu es sérieux, là ?
Laisse tomber, laisse tomber.
(Rires)
Ah !
« Préserver la nature,
ce n’est pas uniquement protéger
les baleines, les tigres ou les pandas.
Vous pouvez agir, par exemple,
en consommant des aliments
issus d’une agriculture durable
ou en réduisant
votre consommation de viande. »
Ah ça, ça, c'est une double bonne idée.
Moins d’eau consommée et moins
de méthane dans notre atmosphère.
« Privilégiez les produits fabriqués
par des entreprises
respectueuses de l'environnement.
Pourquoi ne pas boycotter les banques et
les industries qui ne jouent pas le jeu ?
Vous pouvez agir autour de vous
sans attendre le vote d’une loi.
Vous pouvez aussi agir
en utilisant mieux l’eau de pluie
ou en veillant chaque jour
à ne pas gaspiller l’eau.
Et quelle folie que d’acheter
de l’eau en bouteille
quand on en a de la bonne au robinet,
surtout des bouteilles
qui font le tour du monde.
C’est du n’importe quoi. »
Oui, là, elle est très énervée.
« Mais surtout, n’hésitez plus
à aller planter des arbres
avec les associations le week-end.
Bougez-vous pour les forêts
et les zones humides à côté de chez vous.
Ce sont des éponges naturelles
qui sont menacées
et qu’il faut à tout prix protéger.
Sans forêts, l'eau disparaît.
Et s’il vous plaît,
arrêtez le chacun pour soi.
Asseyez-vous autour d’une table et parlez.
Partagez vos idées
pour mieux partager l’eau.
Je m’appelle Ingo, je suis
une petite goutte d’eau. »
(Applaudissements)
J’avoue l’histoire d’Ingo est triste,
mais il nous appartient
de changer son destin,
de réécrire son histoire pour
qu’elle devienne belle dans le futur.
Et c’est possible finalement chaque jour,
par des bonnes actions de la part
de chacun d’entre nous.
Ingo a raison.
L'eau, c'est notre vie.
L'eau, c'est notre lien.
L'eau, c'est notre partage.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)